i want to give the floor to our special
guest joseph scrimshaw
you gave a great overwhelmingly
positive but also in-depth synopsis
about why you feel the way you do about
phantom medicine these are the kind of
things that
i hear people like you talk about and i
say i need to go back and give this
movie another chance i watched it again
last night
my feeling since maybe 2008
has not really changed on it all that
much so give us a scene
which really illustrates to you the
greatness in this movie and maybe that
shows off some of the
the uh the through lines that george
lucas intended us to see
yeah this was really hard for me because
i could do almost any scene there are a
couple that
i would be a little bit more critical of
but the thing that i really wanted to
pick is
basically the the four-pronged uh finale
the battle
uh you have the lightsaber fight right
that is of course
often the thing that people like that
okay but the lightsaber fight was
awesome because
if you're the kind of star wars fan who
wants a little bit of um a little bit
more edge or a little bit more to the
sith and the badassery uh you have satan
guy with double-bladed lightsaber
having an amazing fight with utterly
charming ewan mcgregor right
in really really different choreography
from the original trilogy so people
really
love that uh but then you also have the
space battle
uh you also have padme uh storming her
own palace uh with blaster fire
and then on the total other end of the
spectrum uh you have
jar jar and the gungans bravely fighting
but with brave fighting that also
contains uh slapstick
in which jar jar's crotch whatever
exists there we do not know
is wounded in the battle right i mean
you have the absolute extremes of what
people love and what people
don't like about this film and i think
for me
why i picked those scenes is i think it
illustrates
both the things i said at the top i
think it illustrates lucas as
an indie artist who says i know you grew
up with the original trilogy people who
are seeing this in 1999 and i know you
want this list of things
i don't care i want to tell you the
story that i want to tell
and that includes everything from an
awesome lightsaber fight to
a fun physical comedy that reminds you
that jar jar is a
a total innocent who is being extremely
brave in this scenario and lucas knows
that
okay i'm gonna get pushback probably but
this is the film that i absolutely want
to make
i don't care if other people think that
it it's got some weird tonal shifts to
me this is my film
the other thing about it is the the plot
of the film definitely does have i think
uh kind of
two threads it's got the invasion of
naboo which is the main thread and then
the threat of
will anakin be trained is he the chosen
one all that stuff and this is really
that moment these four battles together
that shows all these different people
coming together for this common good it
is not right
that a corporation a corporation that
has representation in the senate has
invaded a planet this is basically
amazon in our world just decided because
they don't get enough money
nobody should be able to go in and out
of maryland and
they can't the senate won't act because
amazon has
two seats in the senate i i understand
that sometimes
people don't like the trade stuff but
that to me is what's going on and this
is
those four battles are all these
different people
different perspectives different needs
different wants coming together to end
this injustice
that the senate can't and won't because
it isn't functioning anymore
you know it it's so fun to listen to you
a because i do have trouble even now
deciphering
how dense it's by far the most dense
three paragraphs of crawl text
of any star wars movie in my opinion
it's when the phantom menace kicks off
and you're like
you were so hyped to get in there and
you're like oh okay there's to be some
homework here
but at the end what i love about what
you said joseph is that there's so much
to look at and it does what the classic
star wars movies did too is the climax
of every classic star wars movies
has multiple things sort of going on at
the same time or at least in a new hope
you had
luke and leia trying to escape the death
star at the same time you had han
and chewie mistakenly charging towards a
bunch of storm troopers which became a
lot more stormtroopers with the special
editions
so you always had those like okay this
action's going on here
then we pivot back to this action here
and
the highlight of anybody i think for
phantom menace jaclyn is going to be
the lightsaber fight that does happen
between darth maul
and qui-gon and obi-wan i remember i had
a teacher in high school who was a
little angry at star wars because she
just thought that
the the lightsabers were phallic
representations of the men
using them and i remember thinking oh
come on that's and then
then you see darth maul light is double
you see the other side come out and
you're like oh yeah that might be a um
that might be a phallic thing after all
so it's such a cool fight though and
like joseph said
it is such a leap forward in terms of
choreography and what we had seen in
star wars
up to that point so is that maybe a
scene
that also makes you feel a certain way
about the movie
yeah i mean the duel of fates which is
the epic music that plays underneath
um the darth maul uh
qui-gon jin and then eventually with
obi-wan kenobi fight scene
that moment is probably one of the
greatest moments in star wars in fact i
think
that the cut that topher grace did where
he
cut the prequels into one movie it
actually made kind of sense and it was
like interesting and you enjoyed it
from what i believe i think he starts it
there
like he doesn't even like go through the
entire movie he like starts it pretty
much
right there he doesn't even include the
pod racing so
and a lot of people actually said that
that movie if you watched it which i
think it's somewhere about
320 total for all of them um it's
actually quite
you know clippy and moves and and really
interesting and shows that you know
topher grace is a quite accomplished
editor
anyway that to me says what that scene
really sort of does i
absolutely adore john williams there's a
reason why he is
one has been nominated for more oscars
than any composer in history
and is still going strong and i think
it's an illustrative moment of how
music can power incredible fight
choreography as well like it's just
one of those incredible blendings of i
think great film movie making
and for that i can't really say that
anything is terribly wrong with this
movie altogether
um the the actor um who who did the
fight choreography with that one also
um ewan mcgregor talked about how long
that he worked to get ready for that
scene not just the emotions behind it
but the thing i love about that scene in
particular
is qui-gon jin dies um up against a very
formidable opponent and if you remember
from the scene he actually is meditating
before he goes into that epic battle
and that is the way of the jedi that is
actually the way the jedi
should embark on it to find peace to
find serenity to find
balance in a moment before you go into
this
uh action um but obi-wan kenobi actually
the rage and the grief that he feels
from qui-gon being murdered is what
allows him to defeat darth maul
and that is against what the jedi would
actually believe and so it's
already i think positioning this story
in a way that doesn't
always vibe with the mythology and i
think that is a part
of the phantom menace and the entire
prequels which
because george lucas created them
borrowed them uh whichever you want to
say
um he felt that he could break the rules
in the same way
a classically trained pianist when they
play jazz is gonna break all the rules
that they learn
but you have to know the rules inside
out to know where to break them
and i don't know if george lucas
respected his own
rules as much as other people because
he'd lived with them for 20 years
he'd lived through decades of interviews
and people talking about them
and essentially him knowing that that
was going to be the first line of his
obit no matter what else happened is you
know this is the guy that created star
wars and so
it was almost like a part of him like
his finger and you can't really look at
your finger with the reverence that
somebody else would
and so when he was breaking these rules
like he did in that scene
even the times when it worked if you
look back if i look back on
it now it's nonsensical and i don't
necessarily think
that when you add all of that up it
makes it and also on top of that because
of the thing that george lucas has
always done which is plots are
minimal style is maximum
that doesn't always work when people
have been waiting for 20 years they want
a story that they're invested in
and he was invested in it but not
necessarily the fans
i remember the movie going experience
and just thinking like oh now i actually
have to sit down and watch a movie well
it didn't matter what the movie was it
was you're just so excited to be
and you've been waiting so long and now
it's like oh no i still have to just sit
there and have this story told to me
for two hours and so my favorite part of
duel of the fates is actually
i mean seeing the doors open and seeing
darth maul you know
ignite his lightsaber is pretty awesome
but it is in that moment where obi-wan
i don't know that we're breaking at
least in my opinion i never saw that as
breaking the rules of the jedi i saw
obi-wan sort of tapping into
you know towing the line of the dark
side i look at the dark side sort of
like
the field of dreams out of bounds where
if you step over this line you become
old moonlight graham
and so i luke skywalker had towed that
line many a time
including in the galactic you know uh
the climactic
clash between him and his father in
return of the jedi and then seeing
obi-wan where you have those like those
like weird force fields
that come up every so often seeing darth
maul just
pace back and forth and just staring
down
obi-wan is just so cool and seeing
obi-wan just summon
really he's trying to summon rage he's
trying to summon anything that is not
just blind obi-wan just basically trying
to not poop his pants so i think that
the force is cool
it's like hey if you got to go a little
to the dark side here just to defeat
this guy
just make sure you don't crap yourself
before you defeat darth maul
and you cut him in half but the scene
that really
go ahead joseph please can i real quick
before you get into your scene can i
offer
an opinion on on obi-wan's level of uh
rage and or uh
need to pooper's pants uh yeah for me i
feel like it and it's totally
uh is obi-wan kenobi himself would say i
consider it a point of view thing i
don't think this
point of view is right i think it's my
point of view my interpretation of that
scene
is he is tending toward the rage which
isn't good that he is acting out of you
killed my master i want to kill you
and the choreography looks cool when
they spin and flip but it leads him
to a vulnerability and it is that moment
where he is pressing
in with anger on maul and maul gets the
best of him and
gives him the force push and he flips
down and i think he takes a moment when
he's hanging there
and that's where he becomes a jedi in
that moment of
he is calming down and he is thinking
about the environment and his
surroundings
and maul isn't maul's just slashing at
him mocking him for having fallen
and obi-wan only wins because he does
what obi-wan always does when he wins
which is he calms down
he becomes more aware of the environment
he remembers that qui-gon's lightsaber
is sitting there
and i feel like when he actually defeats
maul it's because he has calmed down and
is being more jedi-like
[Music]
[Music]